good afternoon everybody and you've made
it this far in a conference so like well
done if you're like me you probably
needed a nap earlier today uh I think
that's what happens at this time right
but um hey thank you for coming to see
this talk today so late in the
conference
um quick introduction my name is Graham
Foster I work as a Cloud solution
architect at Microsoft
um
that's been my job for the last almost
two years now but before that I was
pretty fortunate to get to work on some
fairly large like micro service event
sourced event uh type architectures and
uh we have some really smart Architects
throughout the time and picked up some
interesting ideas kind of came up with
some of my own ideas and learned a fair
bit about those architectures from you
know reading watching videos and all
that kind of stuff
so I'm hoping to share a lot of that
kind of fundamental Eventing slash
messaging patterns with you today
got a slide while I want to get out
talking about what an event driven
architecture is
talking about some of the kind of
problems that we have to face when we
come into an event driven architecture
especially when we start breaking things
up into lots of small disparate services
and we kind of move away from these
monolithic applications where we can do
things consistently anatomically in a
database transaction so we're going to
be thinking about patterns like that
and because I work for Microsoft now I'm
going to break apart some of the
services that we offer for hosting
publishing receiving events and try and
layer that into some of the patterns
that we're going to talk about as well
so not so much code in this talk not so
much live demos I didn't really want to
risk a live demo at the end of the
conference I thought that might be kind
of like a little bit dangerous and in
fact because I know we're an architect
hat uh there's a lot of diagrams in this
so I put my draw.io hat on and it's kind
of a weird experience for me because
I've been an engineer for like God 25
years or something but so diagram heavy
uh very very little code just a lot of
core patterns and mapping them onto
Azure services
so to do this I'm going to hang
the ideas and concepts of a use case now
it starts off as a very very simple use
case imagine two Bas and the higher
echelons of their big glossy Tower in a
city like Melbourne and they're walking
around and they've been reading some
Gartner something like that that came up
with an idea it said hey did you know if
only you could manage your employees
well-being status you would realize that
there's a direct link between their
well-being and their productivity
disclaimer I do not think there is a
study that says that
and I hope not I don't know there's
probably like laws against that kind of
thing but the business idea was that if
you could get an employee every morning
to say one to five on how they're
feeling and then suggest something that
they could do go for a walk Brave in
some nice fresh air that they could be
more productive okay but it's very
important we only ask an employee this
once and once only every day
so this is the business requirement and
it's been handed down from the lofty
Heights of the Ivory Tower up there to
the engineering team who are a little
bit pressed for time and they had to
build something they were given a couple
of weeks so
this is what they came up with
this was their first build of this
service and we're going to use this and
we're going to embellish this as we go
throughout the talk and add new
requirements onto it but it's a lazy
team
okay they're quite pragmatic they don't
really want to over complicate something
which I think is you know a pretty good
way to be so they want to build
something that is as simple as possible
but in their opinion you know it will do
the job and we'll do the job okay and
what they've come up with is pretty
straightforward
Graham is going to log in every morning
he's going to enter zero or one to five
on his well-being rating
this system is going to leverage an
existing correspondence service that
already exists in step three there to
send an email to Graham
and it also is going to record that
state in a database it could be Cosmos
database SQL whatever doesn't really
matter it could be a flat file if you
really really want it to be okay so this
is an architecture it's really
straightforward
but if you think about it there's a few
potential problems lurking in here and
it's super important to know what they
are and then make a decision if that is
going to affect what you've done and you
need to go back and maybe re-engineer
this
so I'm looking at it and I'm thinking
well we've got a tight coupling to a
downstream service here right so if that
corresponding service goes down what's
going to happen
that means can we send that email maybe
we can do a little backup and retry but
what if it's down for a couple of hours
or so right could be a potential problem
to this requirement
um what happens if our employee
well-being service is wildly popular and
we realize that that corresponding
service is written on an old j2e server
running on a cranky VM somewhere and we
suddenly overload it at nine o'clock in
the morning with 10 000 requests
and we take it down what if it was
involved in sending regulatory reports
out to the government or something that
could be pretty nasty right
so when I look at an architecture like
this my initial thoughts are well you
know if it's a small company 20
employees if it's okay if we don't send
that email
this could be completely fit for purpose
right super quick super simple let's
ship it and see what happens
so we ship it and we see what happens
and we start getting bug reports that
come flying in you see a lot of those
initial assumption assumptions turned
out to be correct this correspondence
service is actually quite flaky and it
can go down for an hour or two quite
straightforward quite simply it happens
very very often
which means based off our original
architecture those users are not getting
this correspondence they're just getting
errors and this is a problem a we want
the service to be up and B it's turned
out that it was critically important
that we send those messages to the user
so we might need to refactor
re-architect a little bit so what are we
going to do
well let's try and keep the Mantra of
keeping this simple
but as simple as it can be without
getting too complicated and there's a
great pattern for something like this
where we want to decouple services
we can introduce a queue
and we can send the message instead
so if we look at this architecture
really the main change is in number
three there we no longer directly call
the correspondence service
instead we're just going to drop a
message onto a queue a super simple
queue it's a lightweight service it'll
do the job beautifully and it means that
we can decouple that user experience
from the actual back-end system of
sending the message
now there's a couple of other benefits
in here as well right so that Downstream
service we know it doesn't like being
overloaded so we can use a queue to make
sure that we
limit the amount of throughput that
we're putting down onto that
correspondence service it can act as a
bulkhead that's what we call it so we
can send it loads of messages and it
will just kind of hold on to them and it
will allow them to be dispatched by the
well-being emailer in a kind of managed
throughput sort of way
so it's a lovely architecture and if we
look at Azure we've got a few choices
for a service that we can use here so
the two ones that kind of stand out to
me are storage cues and service bus
now our requirement is pretty
straightforward here right so we don't
need uh lots of kind of shiny features
that are proper message boss is going to
give us we don't necessarily need the
duplication we don't need sessions we
don't need transactions uh we don't need
a request response we just want
something that we can offload these
messages to
so in this scenario a storage queue is
actually pretty cool choice right it's
simple it's kind of rock solid the slas
are really big on them so that's great
um it supports this idea of uh
let's say dequeuing those messages using
competing consumers so I'm not sure if
anyone's come across that before but the
idea here is that we've got a whole
bunch of messages in a queue and we want
to take those messages off and we don't
want to do it in a Serial fashion but we
want some kind of protection that if we
fail to process a message we'll retry it
later
so the idea of competing consumers is
that we can leverage a concept of the
storage queue that's called a peak lock
which means that when we want to take a
message of it we don't actually take the
message off instead we look at it at the
head of the queue and we put a lock on
it but another consumer can come along
and when they go to the first the first
message on the Queue they see the one
behind it they don't see the one that
we've taken a peak lock on and then if
we fail to process that message well
that's okay it'll drop into another
storage queue so we can process that
later
so competing consumers means that let's
say it's a quiet time of day and no one
is using that system well we don't
really have a need for much compute to
drain that queue because there's not a
lot in there but as load starts to
increase we can add more consumers as we
need them and spread out that processing
throughout those consumers and then
scale it back down when we don't need it
and if we know we've got physical limits
on the downstream Services we can make
sure that we don't process too much
maybe we lock it to three consumers
because we know that's what we can get
away with
so it's pretty cool supported by storage
queues super simple service we'll do the
job it's kind of nice right
uh there's a potential issue in there
which is that
what happens if that queue goes down
so we write the state to the database
and then we can't send our message
so if potentially still got that problem
in there that we had before but we've
decoupled from the backend system we've
reduced the load off it it's not going
to go down we're not going to take it
down we don't worry if they're deploying
to it so we're getting some works pretty
good let's let's ship it and let's see
what happens
ah man yeah okay they had five lines on
its SLA but you know it's still going
down at certain times of day so we're
finding out that now the users have seen
the correspondence and I heard there was
a HR libel claim someone said that they
were told to go for a walk by a system
and they slipped on some ice but we've
got no audit Trail because we didn't get
a message to them because the queue was
down at that point in time that's a bit
of a fabricated scenario but I'm sure in
your business domains you could find
equally kind of interesting scenarios
so the problem here is that we've
uncovered a hidden distributed
transaction across these services
so if you think back to the old days
everything used to be bundled up in the
monolithic database and when we were
deploying on premise we had access to
these things called two-phase commit
transaction engines if anybody in here
ever managed to configure one then I'd
love to know who you are because you're
probably part of a select bunch of
people in the world but the idea was we
could have disparate databases or
message queues or things like that and
we could actually open a transaction up
that crossed across those different
Downstream services using two-phase
commit
and if one of them failed everything
else would get rolled back
in the cloud we don't have that luxury
for most of our services we're using
managed Services here we've got Azure
functions we've got managed queues we've
got Cosmos databases they all or most of
them support some notion of transaction
against themselves but not against other
services
so what are we going to do like I feel
like we've really hit a roadblock here
oh it turns out there's actually a
really really simple pattern that we can
reach for here
it's called a transactional outbox
pattern and I was trying to find the
source of it earlier but I can't quite
find out where it came from it's one
pattern that feels like it should have
come from Greg or hoppy or somebody like
that in one of his Enterprise
Integration pattern books
but the transactional outbox is so
straightforward and it kind of instead
of solving the problem by working around
the distributed transactions it just
sidesteps it completely and it says well
what about if we only transacted against
one resource
so what we can see here now is number
two uh stores the local state into the
database like we used to but it stores a
bit of extra information inside that
document it stores the intent to do
something in the future
we call it an out box and it's like
saying look you know here's the local
transaction there's a little thing I
need to do later so I'm just going to
put my intent to do it in here
and then we're going to leverage a
feature of our Cosmos database but most
relational databases support something
similar as well we're going to use the
change feed
so we're going to create another
function uh the dispatcher it's a great
name for dispatcher and what it's going
to do is it's going to subscribe to the
cosmos change feed on those documents
and what will happen is every time we
update or insert a new document that
dispatcher function will get notified
and it can look at the document and it
can peek into the Inbox and say ah okay
well I need to send a message now
so what it will do is it will then call
the corresponding service
and then it will go and write the
document back into the database
now you might realize there's a
distributed transaction in there as well
because we're still transacting against
the correspondence service and calling
the database
but it's different this time because we
know the intent to send that message was
stored earlier on
so we know if we fail to do it this time
we'll have another go and then we'll
have another go and eventually we'll get
that message sent which is very
different to the earlier approach where
we just might not get it sent at all
because remember there's no such thing
as like one-time delivery right no
matter who tells you there is
um you either have at least once or at
most once and in this case we're going
for at least once delivery of that
message because we don't think sending
the same message multiple times will be
a problem for our Downstream uh
employees when they get that message
so this is pretty cool right it fits gas
it's vital to guarantee that you do
something when you're communicating
across multiple services this is a
really good pattern here's an example
here's my Cosmos document
it's not code it's Jason I said no code
this is just Jason so I'm good with that
I've got an ID I've got a status I've
got a recommendation I've got an outbox
bang I'll put it in as one document and
send the message later
so that's pretty cool I'm happy with
that let's move along I think we've
solved that problem
okay so it turned out that our employee
rating is actually wildly successful and
we've got a whole bunch of really good
data which is doing the rounds and HR
I've heard about this and they said hey
this this is good this is good stuff
right we want in we want to know about
your data here
so this gets delivered down to our
engineering team I'm saying well what
are we going to do we've got this out
box you send the correspondence
how about we broadcast an event after
we've sent that correspondence
so we go from this little process where
we did one thing and one thing well
which is to send the email
and now we want to chain a second thing
onto that
I'm going to send the email then we want
to broadcast the event so this is
starting to sound awfully like
a workflow
I want to do this I don't want to do
that
and when it comes to azure
I can think of at least three different
services that we have that can support
you in your workflows
so let's go from the top that I wanted
this to be at the bottom because it was
kind of low code but I couldn't make
PowerPoint work that way I'm just not
very good at PowerPoint unfortunately
which is why I'm not very good at lower
codes as well but we have services like
power automate and if you're a business
user and you want to do things like look
at a SharePoint document send an Outlook
email kind of do stuff across those
office type Services then power automate
is your friend it's going to do what you
want it to do it's straightforward it's
wysiwyg
not so good on the CI CD unit testing
I'm not really sure if you could
automate a test against it um maybe
happy to be told you can do
um but I'm not going to use it for this
scenario
now logic apps is the next one that pops
up
on our website we say logic apps is
aimed at Pro integrators and developers
it Pros so I'm not sure if anyone
classes themselves in that category in
here but logic apps give you a similar
type of GUI star workflow where you drag
and drop you have these connectors that
can call out to other services and we
start to see the introduction of like
expression style languages where we can
use kind of these uh Power syntax type
things where we can look at the outputs
from one thing and send it into the next
thing they support cicd which is good
and they have a lot about other box
connectors which is pretty cool so so
maybe that's for you uh personally for
me for this scenario
I'm a development I'm a developer my
development team think this might get a
bit more complicated so they decided
they don't want to use the logicapped
GUI style interface and instead they
want to use these things called durable
functions
if I'm smelling already because I love
durable functions I think they are so
cool durable functions essentially allow
you to write serverless workflows in an
imperative language of your choice
which is pretty cool right so you can
use.net you can use JavaScript
typescript python Powershell Java
support dropped the other day
and what you can do is you can
essentially write code that defines a
workflow but the little parts of that
workflow all run in serverless style
meaning they only come into life when
they need to be there then they
disappear and you know it's it's a
really kind of cool Paradigm and you can
declare you can basically write
imperative code Define all the steps and
let the durable functions run time go to
the hassle of making sure that each of
those steps is guaranteed to run the
whole thing is backed by storage queues
uh I think there's another provider you
can use for it as now as well you can
write unit tests around these things
because they're just dot net code at the
end of the day you can write whatever
logic you want inside them and test it
you can bring in your nuget libraries
and interfaces and all that kind of good
stuff and this is what they look like
so there's two parts really that make up
durable functions we've got the part on
the left that's called the orchestrator
think of this as the code that knows
about the workflow it's where you write
all the steps all the logic it's where
you spin off the new activities it's
where you go in Loops it's where you can
set timers and come back if things
didn't happen and essentially I'm using
uh net code here I left a line of code
in parallel tasks but running from the
top it's the simplest thing you can see
you've got the await task.whenall
context.call activity async
the other part of a durable function are
the activities
so the activities are where you will
write your code which essentially is the
implementation of the individual
workflow steps
so in my scenario here I've got two
activities send message and broadcast
sentiments and you can see at the top
right I've got a send message activity
that just pokes a correspondence service
and then underneath it I have a
broadcast sentiment even better we can
still opt into Azure functions bindings
on these things as well so if I want to
send a message via service boss or
something I can just use my attributes
on the code at the bottom so durable
functions are an awesome way to create
serverless workflows on Azure and indeed
that's what my team have decided to do
so if we look down in the bottom now
um steps five and a are essentially the
durable function in action so the first
step in the change that's going to send
the correspondence by the service and
then number eight will go and broadcast
an event in this case into service bus
um now why don't you service bus and not
event grids or event hubs is a is a
great question uh and I'm sure whatever
answer I come up with somebody will
challenge that answer anyway but for
this particular scenario there's a
couple of things that led me to that
thinking
first is that I'm using Service Plus
because I'm seeing these as discrete
business events
so we talk about event hubs more for
analytical style data where maybe each
data point doesn't have much meaning in
itself I see this as like a fully formed
piece of information that describes some
business activity in my system
so that's one reason I've chosen to use
Service Plus
the second is my security team do not
like public IP addresses and
unfortunately eventgrid does not allow
you to have a subscriber that is on a
private IP address they have to be
public
you can send messages to a service bus
from a event grid but similar thing the
service bus has to be publicly
addressable so if you're in a kind of
Enterprise organization where it's super
important that things are on private IP
addresses unfortunately as cool a
service as it looks you might have
problems getting it through the door
but this is cool we've broadcasted
sentiment out and the HR service have
got a little subscriber and they can go
and listen to that
so
HR a little bit frustrated with us
because we're not sending them enough
information
all we've actually broadcast our
development team are a little bit lazy
is the employee ID the date and the
well-being rating one to five
and they're crying out saying we want to
know what you told them why aren't you
telling us that okay there's not enough
in this event
which leads us to an interesting
question of how much information should
we put in an event when we broadcast it
out
and there are a few different schools of
thought about how to get that additional
information to the end subscribers
now there's two that I've called out
here
first is to create what I think might in
Fowler called it an event Carriage State
transfer
so the idea of event Carriage State
transfer is that we actually put more
information into the event
just in case someone actually wants that
information we don't not know who that
is they might not be there yet but maybe
in a week's time someone's going to want
it so let's put it in let's start
putting more into that event
so it's a cool pattern it means that our
Downstream subscribers can be completely
decoupled from us right we send the
event they can get it and they don't
need us to actually introspect anything
else about that they've got everything
they need in that event
all I would say is I'd be a little bit
careful about that so I've worked on a
project a few years ago I'm going about
like five or six years where we had a
lot of services
broadcasting events around I think it
was about 120 by the time I left and we
found that
each service tended to want a bit more
or need a bit more and a bit more and a
bit more until eventually every event
that was coming off a domain seemed to
have like the entire aggregate route of
that entity in there just so the other
services could work out what they needed
to do
now if you find yourself falling into
that pattern I would probably take a
step back and wonder whether you're kind
of entering you know Nano service kind
of world where you started to break
apart your domains too much they're too
small and they all need to know about
the insides of each other and maybe
start like instead of shooting your pea
shooter into the asteroids start
sticking them back together again and
creating like Goldilocks size services I
don't know if there's a term for like a
right size service maybe like solar like
everyone thought so I was many many
years ago
um so that's one way you could do this
the other way is you could have the HR
service make a call back
to the well-being service to say hey
look employee one this was the date this
was the well-being status what did you
tell them
so that can be a really good pattern if
you need up-to-date information maybe
it's not okay in your events to have old
stale data
maybe you need to go back and get the
latest source of proof I don't know it's
a legitimate requirement right at the
end of the day
but if you do that then the only thing
to be wary of is that you now have put a
coupling back between those two services
so a lot of the patterns we spoke about
around outboxes and intent and single
transactions
you might have to go back to that kind
of world to satisfy your requirement but
these two patterns are both totally
legitimate ways of getting that extra
information to the subscribers of those
events
so this is pretty cool right I'm we're
going with the uh slightly larger event
I think that's what we're going to try
and do let's push it out there and uh
let's see what happens and all is good
which is cool so
said the word event a hell of a lot in
the last 10 minutes or so and it's a
little bit of a just my best carefully a
Minefield when we come to Cloud
providers when it comes to events
because there are so many Dan services
that all seem to be able to do events
for you so let's suspend a few minutes
going through the uh Azure toolbox of
event style services so think a little
bit about where they make sense where
maybe they're not pitched and why you
might choose to use one over the other
so let's start with event hubs it says
event in the word right so this must be
the one to use for all the things surely
for all of your Eventing style uh
patterns
so event Hub works very similar to
Apache Kafka there are differences sure
but the general kind of architecture and
concepts are the same and we refer to
event Hub at Microsoft as a mass event
ingestion engine
imagine you've got Machinery or you've
got log files piling into your web
servers and you just need to get them
somewhere where they can be analyzed
so that's where we talk about basically
smashing event Hub and sending it
millions and millions and millions of
tiny data points
that you can analyze later on
potentially
so we talk about analytical data as
opposed to our business events now again
this is something off our website more
than anything and I think there's a good
challenge around whether event Hub could
be used to send business events as well
but certainly uh if you're thinking
about data points let's say from a
machine down in the plant somewhere and
you're worried about if that machine is
going to break so the vibration is
really useful imagine you've got streams
of data coming off it but each vibration
point is kind of meaningless in its own
but when you start to push these through
stream processing engines maybe uh
stream analytics or HD insights or
something like that you can do
analytical queries over tumbling sliding
Windows like that and start to infer
potential problems that might be coming
up
inside your machines
um event Hub stores data in partitions
so when you create your event Hub
namespace you actually choose a number
of partitions that you want and that's a
really uh delicate thing to get right
because there could be ramifications of
not getting that number right
so one possible thing that could happen
let's say you decided two partitions
what that means is every piece of data
you send to event Hub will essentially
land in one of those two physical
partitions
now when it comes to consume that data
we don't use competing consumers like we
spoke about earlier
instead we organize nodes into what we
call a consumer group and each node
essentially will have Affinity to one or
more partitions so if you have two
partitions and one consumer that
consumer will get the events from both
happy days if you have two consumers
each consumer will align to a partition
and they will get the events in order
that they came out of that partition
if we have three consumers and two
partitions one consumerator there one
consumerator there the other consumer
nothing to do sit there
I'm not gonna do it because of the way
the Affinity works
now that can be really interesting
because it means that you need to make
sure that your politicians are based off
your Highest Potential need to consume
that data not the lowest potential need
to consume it because if you get smashed
with 50 000 events at a single point in
time let's say over a couple of seconds
and you want to churn through those
quickly you can't just spin up new
consumers if you don't have enough
partitions holding that data
so it's quite an interesting choice that
you have to make early on
um people might tell you with event Hub
you can send business messages like
transact against this account
I'm sure you could put a message onto
that but are you going to get poison
message detection are you going to get
deduplication are you going to get
request response if you find yourself
having to build all of those things on
top of your Eventing engine then there's
a possibility that maybe you should have
chosen a message bus instead which
brings us to our second service which is
service bus
service bus is like essentially an
Enterprise message bus so all your
messaging needs we talk about it as
something that you will send your high
value business messages to which I know
I'm sure you could do but it's actually
a really really useful service it's got
a whole bunch of functionality built
into it where you can have uh sessions
we can do filters on topics and
subscribers so one subscriber might not
get every message that comes into a um
into a queue we can have deduplication
support so that if you send the message
multiple times of the same ID on it
service bus will drop a couple of them
and only give you one of those messages
we can do ordering so even if you have
competing consumers that are all kind of
churning through messages where you can
put sessions against sets of messages so
they'll get Affinity to a consumer and
they will only get the messages in that
session we have request response so if
you want to reply to a message then you
can go and send the message back and we
have topics to enable subscribers to
come along
to subscribe to messages
now it's slightly different to event Hub
in that it's very different to event Hub
actually but with service bus if you're
not there at the point a message is sent
you can't just come along later and
subscribe to that queue and see those
messages because they're delivered and
once they're delivered then that is the
end of that message really they don't
find themselves in new queues whereas
event Hub those messages stay there as
long as the retention period is so you
can come along later I think seven days
is the default on standard but I think
it can go up to 90 or something on the
premium tiers so you can bring on other
things to analyze that data later
um in time but with service bus they're
delivered
and they go but both are pull-based
models so you need a consumer you need a
host processor that's fetching those
messages back
so if you set up a service bus binding
in your Azure function there's actually
a function host that is subscribing to
the service bus and is pulling down
messages
which is one of the main distinctions
between service bus and event grid so
event grid has got the word event in it
like event Hub right so it's it must be
the choice for events and it's kind of
cool how it works it's Cloud native and
it's reactive in nature which
essentially means that when you send
event Hub event grid a message it will
deliver it bang to all the subscribers
straight away there's no pulling it will
just call your functional push a message
into your queue
which is pretty cool but the scale is
built is astronomical so if you push a
million messages in a second into event
grid it will call you a million times
which if you're a legacy Downstream
little API running on a single server
like that correspondence service could
probably set you on fire at the point
that you're getting all those messages
coming through so be wary of its scale
and it can only deliver to public
endpoints which is a problem but what we
often see is combinations of services so
you might settle on event grid for all
of your events and concerns but set
service bus as a uh delivery for some
Legacy systems that can't handle the
Freeport so let service bus buffer that
for you and then use competing consumers
on the other side
now the other call out I want to do is
Cosmos change feeds which are quite
similar to event hops
um the other thing I would say about
them is just be wary of allowing
Downstream applications to connect to
your Cosmos change feed because really
that is your internal schema
so what you don't want is to have
third-party systems coupled to your
internal schema and then you need to
make a change because that's going to be
an awful lot of conversations with
people who will tell you like no I don't
have budget to make that change in my
end and I'm more important than you so
you're not allowed to change
so whenever you're sending events think
of your events as contract just like
your apis are right when you define your
Swagger contracts or your wisdle from
back in the day that was like
super fixed you only change that if you
really had to
so similar to that if you are going to
use Cosmos change feeds maybe don't let
people couple to your internal entities
maybe have another collection which has
got your contract entities which are
more fixed in nature
all right so HR are not happy uh
unfortunately because it turns out what
happened is that the correspondence
service didn't like the load that we
were putting on and the correspondence
service started sending emails in an
asynchronous fashion so previously we
sent an email and we didn't hear back
until it was delivered HR have been told
they're not allowed to use the data
until that email has definitely been
sent but now that is asynchronous so
it's not sent when we ask it instead the
correspondence people have said that
they will raise an event from their
system when they finally send that email
and only then should we broadcast our
information out that the correspondence
wellbeing service has finished
so this is starting to get more
complicated now right it's no longer a
do this then do that it's a do this then
sit and wait
event comes back in all right cool
events come back we've sent it now let's
do the other thing so we're starting to
see the beginnings of much more
complicated workflows arising and I want
to work for three fairly common patterns
which will certainly different of how
they go about this
so the first pattern is called a process
manager
um those of you that use in hibernate
may have seen this referred to as a saga
as well I'm going to step back from that
debate but suffice to say that most
implementations I've seen called as a
process manager and we will look at
sagas in a minute which I think is
slightly different but we're going to
implement this using durable functions
still because we can do and the main
change is that number eight down there
the send email
because this is a serverless function we
can actually just put the function the
process to sleep and we can just just
wait just hang off and wait for an
external event to wake you up again
instead of just kind of going through
the motions
so in this scenario what happens is the
function yields it goes to sleep the
more gets sent
and then in number nine the
correspondence service puts another
message and we have a function another
function that lives outside our durable
function called a correspondence service
trigger this one listens to that Service
Plus Q
and every time a message comes in it
looks at it says okay you've sent some
correspondence and I can see my
correlation ID here so I know which
instance of my running workflow this is
related to and then that external
function can grab the durable function
trigger and say the event has happened
at that point in time the durable
function wakes up again and starts to
move on to the next step
so this is called a process manager now
it's got some really good benefits to it
right you can version this whole thing
so I can release a version two of my
durable function and completely change
the process for new workflows that need
to happen so maybe that involves new
steps reordering steps and we can just
do it using slots in Azure functions
and we can have it such that when the
dispatcher number four there initiates
an orchestration one time it initiates
that orchestration the next time it
initiates the one in the green slot
production slot green slot so we can do
things like that and we can allow the
ones that were in process just to run
their course and get to the end and
finish so that's that's pretty cool
being able to version long-running
workflows that's pretty sweet bit tricky
to version in process workflows so for
workflow is halfway through then most
workflow engines have this problem right
it's normally XML spaghetti somewhere
with durable functions it's a pretty
cool implementation it uses event
sourcing behind the scenes but that
means that the order in which the
activity is finished is super important
when the orchestrator replays it expects
things in the order that the code says
they're going to be in so if you go and
change the order of that you could find
yourself in a bit of a mess so
versioning in processing not so good
you find with durable functions that a
fair amount of boilerplate logic starts
to slip into your code sometimes it can
be hard to look at a more complex
workflow and see the logic because it's
just a lot of call activity async wait
for external event async and it's like
oh you know where where is it where
where's the logic gone to that can be a
bit of a downside to them but a process
manager in general can be really useful
let's say you need to report on the
status of all in-process workflows let's
say I've got
1050 loan applications going or
something they're all on running
workflows how many are at this stage how
many at that stage because there's a
central thing that actually knows about
that workflow we can ask it we can say
to it hey what's the status of all the
in-process workflows and it can give us
that information right so that's that's
pretty cool
um but with durable functions in general
the more external Services the more
complicated these become then the
durable function can get quite
complicated and difficult to reason with
so there are some good points some bad
points it's a brilliant tool to have in
your toolkit is it always the right
choice probably not is it sometimes the
right choice yeah probably it is
so let's flip it completely on its head
process manager has got a central
orchestrator what about if we just
completely do a way of the Central
orchestrator and we have no Central
orchestrator at all
I was watching stranger things uh season
two last night and it reminded me of the
hive mind at the end where you know they
heat one bit of it and everything's like
ah I'm on fire
with a orchestration there is no Central
orchestrator of this workflow instead
the behavior the process itself kind of
arises based off the interactions
between topics and subscriptions between
different services
so you can't point at a place and say
that's where the logic is instead the
logic is everywhere and it kind of
arises so if we look at this now there
is no durable function anymore instead
the dispatcher just raises an event says
well-being was recorded
we have two services to correspond this
in the HR service they both listen to
that event
ah okay correspondence service says this
is great I've got an event here I need
to go and send an email because I know
that's what I do when I see this event
the HR service here's the event and it
says oh okay so the well-being is kicked
into action but
I can't do anything yet right because I
know I need to wait for the
correspondence to be sent so if you're
like I'm going to go into a mini kind of
process manager State myself where I
wait for the other event to come in and
then it subscribes to the events from
the correspondence service when it gets
the event that it says okay cool now I
can use this data
um we did have a requirement that said
that we had to send the email so often
what you'll see in scenarios like this
and the other one is maybe a timer event
somewhere where it's almost like this is
my timeout and if I don't hear that the
email was sent in 30 seconds then I'm
going to send that message again
so he's kind of the weird sort of things
you need to think about when you're
building these kind of distributed
workflows but this is a choreography
approach
um very difficult to version these
because where's the logic right how do
you version that thing when it's running
in process how do you roll out version
two you'd need like a whole new set of
cues you'd need to get every service
lined up to listen to the new topics and
to react differently and you know it
would be a bit of a communication
um problem could be a lot of ocm
involved in getting getting something
like that rolled out but it's a super
elegant model right because you know the
logic just arises it's kind of beautiful
uh in a way
um as more events come on board and the
kind of the processes get more
complicated then this can become
extremely complicated like it's one
thing not to be able to pinpoint the
logic it's another just to have no idea
like what the state of anything is
because like there's a thousand things
involved in it
if you want to know the status of all
the in process workflows a little bit
trickier like you might need to build
another service that listens to all the
events coming off the services that are
involved and starts to build up its own
reporting view of the world right you
can do it again but it could be a little
bit complicated
so I tend to find that these things work
really well almost at the end of your
business process so maybe the process
manager is the thing that you want to
actually uh orchestrate and organize
your logic
because there's a business process you
can almost find a document for it in the
organization and codify it but at the
end of it to allow other services to
react and to do things that are
unrelated to that process raising events
is a really nice way to let the rest of
the world know that your think has
finished
so again it's it's a way you can run a
long-running distributed serverless
workflow another tool to have in your
belt it's pretty cool
Choice four that was interesting choice
two to Choice four I don't remember
choice three
there is no choice three for just seeing
things Choice four is a pat ah hold on
I've lost a slide somewhere how did I do
that oh my God right hold on two seconds
that's so embarrassing
where did it go to
hahaha
all right how is the undo buffer going
to work for me
this is why you should never do things
last minutes
all right I'll tell you what we don't
need a slide for it we can imagine it we
can just imagine it it was a pattern
called a saga pattern right and um oh
hold on is that gonna wait for me oh no
something had to go wrong on the last
Talk of the day right
oh I didn't touch anything Perfect all
right there's a pattern called The Saga
that that's not working as well sorry
I'd have a slide for this one anyway
um imagine if you step back into the
1920s and you went into a big
organization and you said hey Acme
Corporation how are you going to run
this long-running business process
oh okay well we should go to start in
this department we're going to get a big
brown manila envelope and we're going to
put something inside it that details the
process that we need to happen we're
going to do a little bit of it in this
department over here and we're going to
write a list of names on the front of
that envelope and we're going to put it
onto the uh internal mail
and then the mail person will take that
if you look at the next name and he'll
say okay I'm going to take that to
Department two over here
open it up I can see okay I can see what
I'm trying to do here I can see my bit
of the instructions so what I'm going to
do is do my bit and then I'm going to
look at the front of the envelope I'm
going to cross my name off the envelope
I'm going to put it back onto a mail
truck and so on and so on and so on it
will go through all the different
departments
if something goes wrong during that
then the department that had the problem
will put some information about what
went wrong in there
and then they will start the envelope
going back through the Departments that
it came from giving each department an
opportunity to roll back or compensate
because we can't always roll back in
these worlds compensate the behavior
that they enacted upon that workflow and
then it will go all the way back to the
start giving everybody a chance to
compensate
so we refer to that as a saga basically
and with the tools that we've just used
we can Implement a saga really nicely we
didn't need a dual function we don't
have events in the same way instead we
have the well-being process start off
with a simple message it puts on service
bus that has got the names of the cues
in the headers that it needs this
message to flow between and it puts the
message onto the bus where it goes to in
this case the correspondence service
first of all which sends its email it
then looks at the headers and it says
okay cool well now that message needs to
go to the broadcaster HR the broadcast
topic and so on and everything that's
interacting with that has a chance to a
put some business value over it and B if
things didn't go well then it can just
start the message going back up the
chain instead
so that's three very different
approaches to how you could Model A
workflow using sequences of cues and
messages and events that have each got
their pros and cons associated with them
and there's not a wrong or right answer
to these problems it's just look based
off the pros and cons of the business
criteria
come up with a good decision Matrix and
work out which is the the better
approach because they'll all get you
where you need to be which is the
approach that fits the problem that
you've got would be my main advice now
there's number four
let's see if I can get this working
right
oh my word now powerpoint's got into one
of those super weird things where I have
my screen now Frozen awesome
it's all right I've got time I can make
this work
right slide one
two
things are moving awesome
too good CT
a
events HR
choreography Choice four third party so
we've used Primitives so far to deliver
our work for us we've gone really raw on
queues and events and service buses and
event grids which are all awesome
building blocks
but the thing is once you get into more
complicated scenarios with messaging you
find yourself having to write a lot of
abstractions on top of those to really
allow you to just focus on writing the
business logic and get away from the
idea of like cues and subscriptions and
you know all that boilerplate stuff that
we'd rather avoid
and it turns out there's a whole bunch
of pretty cool libraries out there that
can really help you with this that sits
on top of our services not just ours but
other clouds as well they abstract that
away from you and they just give you an
abstraction layer that makes much more
sense in messaging applications so I've
picked on mass transit here there's
obviously end service bus as well and
I'm sure there's a whole bunch of other
ones so another way you could rewrite
this is to literally uh use in this case
I've got a container app which is a
great way to run a long-running process
now in Azure which we've only just uh
got which is awesome it can sit there as
a Daemon process and mass transit will
deal with all the subscriptions to the
queues and things like that that we need
and then it will just allow us to write
our business logic that defines what
happens when the different messages
start to come in now these things are
awesome but the only thing I'd say to be
aware of is that they really need you to
start to opt in other parts of your
organization as well because just having
one service running on one of these
abstractions like mass transit well
there's a lot of stuff that's doing
under the scenes to deal with like
subscriptions and routing and things
like that that you know either get your
other services using the same thing or
that's going to be difficult to only
have one service in that world
so again another option if you're all in
on this then this could be a really good
way to go because you just get the
abstractions given for you and they
leverage the underlying services and get
all the first class goodness from them
so there you go uh so oh we're not gonna
go for that one because I'm not going to
have time for event sourcing and
there's a whole bunch of considerations
uh like they're on top of what we've
spoken about today that you really need
to think about in this kind of
architecture so things like you know
you've got your messaging your hosting
Services uh processing type but then
correlation IDs durability partitioning
back offs retries item Post-it receivers
you name it all sorts of stuff that is
going to be important when you're
building these architectures but I hope
that I've given you a little bit of an
insight into the Azure services and the
way that we can put them together and
leverage them to help build these
distributed event-driven architecture
type applications
so thank you very much thanks for
varying with me when it all went wrong
uh in my little slide deck there and any
questions that you have then feel free I
think we've got a few minutes left so go
for it
yes go for it
I probably applies less to an event and
more to a message really or although
having said that I did look earlier um
so if you think about service bus so the
question was what is request response in
uh consideration of an event
um in Service Plus these things are all
just messages at the end of the day so
no matter whether you receive that
message on a queue or a topic so in
service bus queues are kind of like
point to point where you put a message
on a queue there's a single thing that
reads off that queue I topic is this
idea of wanting many where you put a
message and pointed at a topic you can
have different subscribers that will all
receive that message in their queue
they'll all get their own copy of it and
request response is just this idea that
you can actually put a message back onto
a queue that refers to the original
message so it just means a message flows
back down into the originating system so
whether that's on a subscription or a
point to point it doesn't really matter
in service bus world
so a good example might be let's say
you have got a system that wants to put
a message on to uh drive a live online
auction where you might have lots of
different
um
services that can potentially put
something onto that page so you might
put it onto a queue but in each one
potentially will respond within let's
say a third of a second and the first
few that come in with the response maybe
you'll use that to drive your UI cool
yeah go for it
um yeah look it's it's not a big like in
all honesty
um the change feed gets updated the
moment that you persist the document
right that's a very quick thing the lag
would be in your own thing that Paul's a
change seat because that's a polling
model so and and you know you probably
don't want to smash to change feed
because you'll get rate limited against
it so you tend to go maybe every second
or something like that but really it
should be no more than a couple of
seconds that you get the change coming
in unless there's thousands of changes
and then obviously you've got to work
through them
is there any other types of
patented
I've ran into bulb problems and stuff
like that and obviously that's why
yeah other types of scenarios like
like retry in to send the message yep
absolutely yeah
um
you know if you want to really just
transact against a single system then if
you're a service like you're a
microservices owns its own data it's
it's a really good way of doing it you
could always retry against a downstream
system but you know again it depends if
it's super critical that you transact
across by for those systems then outbox
I think is a really good way to go
if you can deal with not sending a few
of those messages then you can
definitely keep it simple by simpler by
having a bit of back off and retry and
then just saying that I couldn't do it
for that one but I think it comes back
down to your business requirements and
how important is it to send that message
cool all right going once
going twice the end of conference
approaching rich as locked down thank
you everybody for coming today